Oh
[Music]
welcome to the IBM BPM eight five seven
zero demonstration on grid support in
this demonstration I will create a
simple user interface for requesting
travel within an organization to start
with I'm going to create a client-side
teaming service called travel request to
start we're going to add a variable to
capture the information about the
request our variable name will be called
travel request and the type of bed
variable will be the trouble request
business objects that I created earlier
I'm going to go back to the diagram tab
now and we're going to rename the
default coach to gather info next step
we're going to go to the coach's tab
we're going to click on gather info and
here you'll see the first difference
compared to previous versions of BPM we
have a new option here called start with
grid this allows you to quickly get
started with a grid on your new coach I
have an idea of what my layout should
look like so I'm going to choose the
header footer starting point for my grid
and click OK once the layout loads you
can see we have three cells within our
layout which can be populated with
content from the palette
although this grid is a good starting
point I want a different grid for my
layout in order to change the grid I'm
going to go into grid editing mode using
these radio buttons in the top right
corner here content mode allows you to
add layout items to the canvas grid is
the mode used to edit the grid I'm going
to click the grid video button and we
can see that the editors change to allow
me to edit the grid I want first name
last name and employee number across the
top so I want to create two more cells
to do this I can just hover over any
cell or container within the grid and
click the plus icon this easily allows
me to add a new cell I will add another
one next I want to resize my cells so
that they're evenly spaced across the
top in order to do this I all I have to
do is hover over the right edge of a
cell as I drag you can see there's a 12
column
parlez the available width of the coach
is divided evenly into 12 column all
cells are aligned to these 12 columns
I'm going to complete the resize of the
cell and then I'm going to resize the
next cell to be also four columns wide
next I want to split the middle area
into half I will do that using the same
technique clicking the plus icon to
create that new cell I'm going to leave
the bottom cell as is that's going to
hold the buttons within our coach our
grid is now complete and I'm going to
switch to the content for you to
populate it I'm expanding the variables
within my palette and I'm going to drag
and drop some of the fields into the
grid as I'm dragging you can see that
all cells are highlighted even ones that
have content already next I'm going to
add some of the fields dealing with the
destination for the request I'm going to
add a map view to the right of those
fields the map is going to show the
postal code area on a map finally I'm
going to drag my okay button into this
bottom cell and create a companion
cancel button I now have my coche
authored with a grid the last thing to
do is to set the binding on the map and
then run I will run the client-side
human service to inspect the Coache
layout at runtime if I adjust the width
of the browser we can see the columns
within the grid dynamically adjust if I
make the browser with very small we can
see the layout does not look very good
our next step is going to be to make the
grid responsive to smaller device sizes
to make our layout responsive we're
going to go back to the editor and make
changes to the top middle and bottom
sections of our layout to start with
we're going to deal with the top
I'm going to go into the grid editing
mode and go to the medium device size
what we want is to have a little bit
more room for each of these fields in
order to do this I'm going to resize the
cells on the medium device size the
horizontal span of the cells are
device-dependent finally switching to
the small device I'm going to set the
width of these cells to span the entire
width of the device next we're going to
make the middle section responsive to
start with we're actually going to
change some positioning and
configuration options on the views
themselves on the map coach view which
is the custom coach view that I authored
I have a responsive configuration option
for the default map type we're going to
set that to satellite enlarged we're
also going to set the height to be 400
pixels because we do have quite a bit of
real estate on a large device next on
the medium size we're going to change
the height to 300 pixels and we're going
to configure the coach view to be Road
by default lastly I'm going to change
the rendering of the is customer travel
field to be a switch on medium and
smaller devices finally on this small
device size we realized we don't have a
lot of real estate at all so what we're
going to do is hide the map completely
on this device to do that we're going to
click on the grid editing mode select
the cell that contains the map and set
it to be hidden on small devices we can
then take the remaining cell and resize
it so it spans the entire width
we've now hidden the map on small
devices and given the destination fields
enough real estate finally we're going
to adjust the bottom section which
contains the buttons first what we're
going to do is change the layout of the
cell
Sol's can lay out their content both
vertically and horizontally because
these are buttons we're going to lay
them out horizontally on a large device
we want them right aligned to match the
desktop paradigm on medium device sizes
I want the buttons to be larger and
centered in order to do this I'm going
to change the alignment the alignment is
a responsive setting as you can see from
the icon to the left of the field now
that we have the button center lined
we're going to go to the content editing
mode this will allow us to change the
positioning properties of the buttons
and make them wider previewing the small
device size we can see our buttons still
look decent and we will leave it as is
to complete our client-side human
service we're going to add another
screen to show the map when on a small
device size to get to this map we're
going to add another button to our
layout this button is going to be called
you map we only want this button to
appear on small device sizes so we'll go
to the visibility we'll set it to be
required on the small size switch to
large and set its visibility to none on
the diagram we're going to add a new
coach to view the map
and I will wire it to the button I just
created when selecting view map were
given the same dialog in this case we're
not going to use a grid because it's
going to be a very simple coach we'll
create an instance of the map coach view
bind it to the postal code set its
height to be 400 pixels and that
completes this coach let's run the
client-side human service to see the
final behavior we can see on large first
name last name employee number each
share a third of the horizontal space
across the top its customer travel near
the check box our map is satellite by
default and the ok and cancel buttons
are right-aligned if we adjust the
browser width to medium size we can see
that first name last name employee
number are all 50% of the browser width
that's employee number flowing on to the
next line the ok and cancel buttons are
now larger and aligned to the center
customer travel is now a switch and our
map is road by default if I make the
browser width even smaller we are not
the small device setting the map is
completely hidden all of our fields are
now spinning the entire device width
which would be very useful on a device
such as a phone if I click the view map
button we are taken to another screen
with the map showing and that concludes
the demonstration grid support is a
simple and intuitive way of laying out
the route content in your coach and
coach views which is both lightweight
and responsive at runtime thank you
[Music]